welcome to the show everybody I hope you
had a better weekend than I did I guess
I spoke too soon on Friday because I
said I've been sick today before but
then I was better well shortly after
shooting the show I was in the hospital
hooked up to an IV mask you know the
whole nine yards I had the flu
turns out turns out I had the flu time
so so I finally got to see what the buzz
is about the flu buzz what would all the
flu hype is about and I can report that
it pretty much sucks as much as
everybody says it does I thought maybe I
could though the one good thing about
having the flu I thought is I could come
up with a contrarian take like I like to
do and maybe I could come and report
that actually the flu is good but I
can't it's it's not good i I just I have
to agree with with the general consensus
that it's it's not very good at all
and we have four kids at home so I had
to quarantine myself in our room
upstairs for three days
with the help of my my wife who you know
I I was I was like basically like The
Hunchback living in the bell tower and
my wife would come up push a plate of
gruel under the under the door a couple
times a day then run away if I tried to
come downstairs she'd turn the hose on
me get away I'm clean and that's pretty
much what it was like and but now I'm
relatively okay and and ready to get
down to business so alright um a number
of interesting things came up over the
last few days maybe they just seemed
interesting to me because I was in a
feverish haze I don't know but let's
start with famed biologist and atheist
Richard Dawkins on Sunday sent out some
tweets about eugenics now what he said
what he actually said is is not so much
the interesting part as the reaction to
what he said so let's start with that he
this is what he wrote he said it's one
thing to deplore eugenics on ideological
political or moral grounds it's quite
another to conclude that it wouldn't
work in practice of course it would
it works for cows horses pigs dogs and
roses why on earth wouldn't it work for
humans facts ignore ideology for those
determined to miss the
I deplore the idea of a eugenic policy I
simply said deploring it doesn't mean it
wouldn't work just as we breed cows to
yield more milk we could breed humans to
run faster jump higher but heaven forbid
that we should do it
now I'm not exactly sure what prompted
this or why you know it's necessary to
make the point that hey eugenics is bad
but it would totally work if we did it
hint hint it's bad we shouldn't but if
we did it'd be great but we shouldn't
not sure the point in that but
nonetheless Dawkins says eugenics would
work in practice even if there are some
moral some ethical and moral
complications with it what fascinated me
is that Dawkins was roundly mocked and
condemned for what he said here across
the board from what I could tell liberal
conservative religious non-religious
everybody everybody said was was against
it I even I read a post just just before
the show started in an atheist blog and
they were confusing they were rather
criticizing it as well and this to me
just shows how confused we are as a
people as a culture most people don't
have a coherent worldview or philosophy
it's like we're all just making it up as
we go along and often deciding our our
views our principles based on the mood
of the social media mob whoever's
getting ratioed on Twitter we all just
take the opposite view of whatever that
guy said even if we agree with it here's
the point with eugenics yes I believe
that the practice is barbaric and in a
very literal sense dehumanizing so I'm
against it and if you're a pro-life
conservative you're probably against it
consistently so but if you're on the
Left then you probably already support
eugenics it's happening right now and
it's it's it's not only do you support
it but it's a big part of your worldview
of your philosophy as I said right now
in our society it's happening and if
you're on the left then you support it
so you
you have no reason to take issue with
anything that Dawkins said Planned
Parenthood was first of all founded by
one of the most vocal eugenic advocates
of the 20th century Margaret Sanger and
if you think that all of the eugenics
stuff died with her back fifty years ago
you're wrong in fact it's it's almost
the opposite
um arguably it didn't even start until
she was dead she was gone it wasn't
until five or six years after she died
that Planned Parenthood even started
killing babies started performing
abortions Margaret Sanger was actually
relatively opposed to abortion in many
cases anyway so when you read the
horrible things she said and she said a
lot of horrible stuff but remember that
she was more ethical more moral than the
people who run Planned Parenthood today
even though she was a genesis and and in
a very morally deranged person in many
ways she would probably be horrified by
what plant pet what by what her or own
organization is doing now which tells
you a lot about her organization and
what does Planned Parenthood do well it
eradicate the babies of predominantly
poor mothers often racial minority
mothers and it does so expressly
explicitly on the basis that these
children are unwanted and would be a
drain on society that is one of the
primary arguments advanced for abortion
and that is a eugenic argument that is a
eugenicist argument there unwanted
strains on society so we got to get rid
of them
here's an even clearer example Down
syndrome in Europe over 90 percent of
Down syndrome babies are aborted 90% in
some European countries that number is
basically a hundred percent they've all
but eradicated quote-unquote the
condition in many European countries by
killing everybody with it
that's eugenics what about this country
here it's about 70 to 75% of Down
syndrome babies that are killed again
that's eugenics so if you've got a
problem with eugenics you should have a
problem with this if you don't have a
problem with this then at least admit
that your supporter of eugenics you see
well we'll never this is why I'm always
going on about intellectual consistency
and honesty because we're never gonna be
able to communicate with each other or
understand each other or get anywhere in
any of our arguments about things if
we're not beginning from a place of
honesty and intellectual consistency we
have to be honest about what we believe
and what we want and what we value and
prioritize because there's so much bad
faith arguing so much confusing
confusion so much internal inconsistency
where you have just as one example
people who defend Planned Parenthood's
eugenicist agenda and yet at the same
time attack a guy who says that eugenics
works who's on their side
because they're not being honest with
themselves about what they believe
because I guess when you're a little bit
too honest about it and you admit to
yourself that yeah you know I here's
what I think that one of the ways to
solve the poverty problem is just to
kill poor babies when you say that to
yourself when you admit it out loud when
you put it like that it sounds horrible
and it even you recoil from it but that
should tell you something when you take
your own views out of your head and you
strip them of all the euphemism and you
just look at them for what they are or
when you hear somebody else repeat them
back to you in a way that is not as
sanitary and you're horrified by it well
that should tell you there's something
about your worldview and until people
are willing to do that and face their
own worldviews we're going to have again
nothing but confusion here's something
that's not confusing though Tacomas
Tacomas cowboy boots are handmade with
high quality full grain leather by
world-class boot makers I can tell you
I am wearing them right now I pretty
much worn them nah I wear them to bed
almost ever since the guys at katha
koba's sent me a pair of the boots
they're built to be comfortable right
out of the box for every occasion
whether you're at home in the office
your your you know out on the town
whatever you're doing going to a rodeo
you know whatever it is that you're
doing you you you need these cowboy
boots with tons of timeless styles to
koba's are designed to be as fashionable
50 years from now as they are today
that's the thing with it's one of the
reasons why I think a lot of people
myself included
it's just with with fashion and trends
it's not worth keeping up with them
because it you know you you go out
people that try to keep up with trends
you spend all this money getting the
trendiest shoe or whatever five minutes
later it's not trying to anymore well if
you're getting something like Tacomas
they're timeless they're classy they're
beautifully made and that's gonna be the
case now 50 years ago fifty years from
now it doesn't matter the Kobus cuts out
the the middleman sells direct to you at
an honest price that's truly amazing for
the level of quality that they provide
plus shipping returns and exchanges are
free and easy in addition to cowboy
boots Tacomas makes leather duffels
men's jeans belts billfolds card cases
everything you get from the Kovas comes
with the the same calculated approach at
quality standards that hold true to
everything they do and it just feels
great wearing these shoes walking down
the street just it just makes you feel
confident and you know what else it
makes you feel like a man if I could
just say that so do what I did get
yourself a pair of two Kovas cowboy
boots today at tacoma's dot-com slash
walsh that's tec ova Escom slash walsh
Tacomas dot-com slash Walsh
so Mike Bloomberg just got himself
qualified for the next democratic debate
as he surges in the polls latest
national poll has a mat that I saw was
at nineteen percent which is pretty
astounding one thing I've learned over
the last few years is that I really have
no clue what's going on well I learned
that every day in life basically but
especially the last few years as it
pertains to politics I I just have no
idea
I didn't see Bloomberg the billionaire
stop-and-frisk guy finding any traction
at all I remember when he jumped into
the race back in November and I was
joking about how this is someone who
seems tailor-made speaking of being
tailor-made he's tailor-made to not
appeal to anybody like he doesn't check
anybody's boxes you would think white
old male billionaire stop he's got the
stop-and-frisk thing going on
pro-abortion liberal nanny-state so who
you would think who is he appealing to
yeah the Liberals might might like the
pro-abortion part and some of the nanny
state stuff but he's what but you know
they're not going too crazy about white
old billionaire male then you got the
stop-and-frisk I mean and then on the
other hand conservatives successful
businessmen they might like that but
then all the ideological stuff nanny
state pro-abortion so you would think
doesn't appeal to anybody but yet in the
polls anyway here we are now in fairness
he hasn't actually won a Democratic
primary state yet and maybe he never
will I mean if he it would be kind of
depressing in many ways
if you were to actually start gaining
real support in primaries and let's say
win the nomination because then you have
to think is really that easy to get
people to support you you put it you put
a bunch of ads out is it really that
easy people because they see you on TV
they're gonna think actually yeah maybe
that guy would be a good president is it
as easy as that I don't know I'm still
skeptical of Bloomberg's chances though
again what do I know nothing at all but
if he does become the nominee I also
think that he would present an
interesting challenge for Trump because
Bloomberg you know with Bloomberg you
have a much more successful businessman
let's face it than Donald Trump this
Bloomberg is worth what 67 million bill
it billion billion dollars with a with a
company that he basically did build on
his own and so you know he can do that
he can do the successful businessman
deal maker thing that Trump does
arguably he can play on that turf even
more credibly than Trump can so what's
the line of attack yeah Trump calls him
short I don't know if just calling him
sure it's gonna be enough with this guy
you could bring up all of the
politically incorrect stuff that
Bloomberg has said but then of course I
mean it's Donald Trump we're talking
about that be a little bit off-brand for
Donald Trump to try to win an election
by pointing out the offensive things the
other guy said so um I'm not exactly
sure what the line of attack is but
here's the one thing that that you put
everything else aside put all the
traditional thoughts aside seems to me
this is though this is the one thing
that would that would prevent Bloomberg
from maybe becoming president in the
year 2020 and that is that even if he
can generate support depressingly so
with his money just by buying a bunch of
ads because a lot of people are just
sheep and they see the ads on TV and
they say oh yeah okay I'll bow for him I
saw a I saw him on TV he must be good
but I don't think
that just by buying ads you can generate
a cult of personality around you and I'm
wondering if we have entered a point in
American history where you just can't
win the presidency without a cult of
personality without a savior cult
following you around and worshiping you
the last three elections you know have
been decided that way Obama then Obama
again Trump you know they all had cults
of personality still do Bernie Sanders
right now leading the pack among
Democrats he's got a cult of personality
if Bernie Sanders is the nominee that's
gonna I think pretty much seal it and
we're gonna know that's that's the
reality of the world we're living in
right now politically where if you want
to have a chance to win the presidency
you have to have a cult you have to have
a it's all gonna come down to
personality cults and that's a very
dangerous trend not unprecedented
certainly in the history of the world
obviously it's not the first time that
we've had people finding political
success based on cults of personality
but it's also not it hasn't always been
this this way you know George Bush I
don't think really had a cult of
personality I'm not even sure that I
wouldn't even say that that Bill Clinton
did but are we are we entering a point
in American history where that's the
case I hope not you know I really do
there's a lot of there's a lot of great
reasons not to vote for Bloomberg and
there's a lot of there are a lot of good
reasons to print reasons for him to lose
but I hope that's not the reason he
loses or that anyone loses I hope that's
not what decides the election okay let's
talk about this as much as I prefer not
to report by Paul Bois and The Daily
wire says disturbing video has
re-emerged featuring the famous 12 year
old drag queen Desmond a pole and the
police I think is I pronounce his last
name
aka Desmond is amazing pretending to
snort ketamine another video featured
him being interviewed by convicted
killer Michael alig
according to Blair white of the post
millennia
the clips feature Desmond featuring
Desmond were posted to YouTube in July
2018 into December 2017 though various
media outlets including red state and
National Review reported on the videos
in 2018 the recent report from
transgender Blair White has further
amplified the public's attention towards
them Blair's recent video on the subject
has since garnered over half a million
views in the first video Desmond has
shown talking to the camera alongside
drag queen Bella noche while appearing
to answer Internet user comments during
a livestream at one point later on
Desmond mimics a snort when Bella noche
mentions the drug ketamine let me go
ahead just play this this video this is
from as it said a live stream and it
looks like some stuff spliced together
but just watch this see how this kid is
acting and then you tell me does it seem
like this kid is on drugs or not watch
this your mom can do jak 1 for 8 people
can have a bunch of bait up genders
that's not what see Bella noche putting
the P and L GBT P plus you just eat
little nipper
but I'm kidding I'm getting hate
comments is you know famous now is this
what he wants lots of respect for you
guys thank you press G the gas gggg 1 2
3 4 G what has this world come to it's
come to a world where drag kids actually
exist and people do ketamine on a couch
how old is your BF hello Hitler was one
helicopter ride yay now keep in mind
again that video is from when this kid
was about nine years old so that's
that's a nine-year-old you're seeing
there how does it 9 just to start with
how does a nine-year-old know what
ketamine is much less how to imitate
snorting it my kids my twins oldest kids
are almost 7 years old so they're not
that much younger then what then what
Desmond is in that video and I mean it's
unfathomable it's unfathomable to have
to think of my kids acting that way
well how does he know about ketamine how
does he know about snorting it well I
mean look at him
look at how he's acting it's it's no
mystery the kid is very clearly on drugs
and this is something that it's not just
that the left is tolerating this it's at
they're they're celebrating it
the continued abuse and exploitation of
this kid it's not just merely will put
up with it they said they are standing
and literally applauding it I mean
literally in person going and applauding
it we'll talk more about that in just a
second
but before we do quick word from policy
genius you know
the year 2020 shows up a lot in science
fiction a lot of people predicted that
by now we'd be teleporting to work or
living on Mars or you know a lot of
different predictions many of them were
wrong although we do have jetpacks now
at least I just saw a video of a guy
flying around a jetpack and Dubai so
we've got that at least but not much
else in terms of what it was predicted
the truth is we're always going to get
the future wrong which is why we need to
get life insurance right that's where
policy genius can help policy genius
makes finding the right life insurance a
breeze in minutes you can compare quotes
from the top insurers to find your best
price you could save fifty nine dollars
or more a year by using policy genius to
compare life insurance policies once you
apply the policy genius team will handle
all the paperwork all the red tape and
policy genius doesn't just make life
insurance easy they can also help you
find the right home and auto insurance
disability insurance so if your
science-fiction dreams for 2020 still
have not become a science fact don't get
discouraged get life insurance it takes
just a few minutes to find your best
price and apply at policy genius.com
policy genius will always get the future
wrong better to get life insurance right
okay back to the daily wire report on
the drugged and abused dragged kid
Desmond a little bit more from the daily
wire since the second video which
occurred when Desmond was just 10 years
old featured him being interviewed by
Michael alig a lig who was convicted of
first degree manslaughter in 1997 for
the killing of angel Melendez
the New York Times provided more details
of the case
I'll read a few of these details just so
you understand who this guy is that this
this kid is hanging around with and it
says in his statement to the police
Robert Briggs said that mr. Alec and mr.
Melendez had been fighting and that he
had intervened to save mr. mister a
league hitting mr. Melendez over the
head with a hammer and knocking him
unconscious he said that mr. Alec then
throttled mr. Melendez importing
detergent into his mouth before wrapping
it with duct tape the two men then dump
mr. Melendez his body in their bathtub
about five to seven days later okay all
right well we get the point there beat
him with a hammer bleach in the mouth
okay just to summarize this young boy's
despicable awful monstrosity of a mother
started dressing him in drag at around
the age of two next thing you know he
was quote performing in drag shows
dancing at gay nightclubs gay men
throwing dollar bills at him hanging out
with convicted murderers and by the
looks of it doing drugs this all before
the age of 12 and what is the response
from society to this from the media from
the left from the government is his
mother being carted off to jail in
shackles locked in a cage where she
belongs
no instead she gets as I said applause a
Jew Latian standing ovation money just
as one example of that let me play this
for you this is a news report by ABC the
ABC affiliate in New York keep in mind
the clip I just played before of this
obviously drugged child pretending to
snort ketamine with an adult
crossdresser on a couch so keep that in
mind as you watch this cheerful little
puff piece about the drag kid Desmond
watch
hi I'm dozens amazing only ten but
already an activist advocate model and
fashion icon Desmond appleís has come a
long way since his first pride march in
2015 overnight I was like everywhere and
Desmond is still everywhere
he has 65,000 Instagram followers he's
appeared on talk shows and
alongside his idol RuPaul I saw these
Queen and they were so amazing that I
decided that I would take my mom's
clothes shoes towels wrapped around
myself to make pretend Desmond's mom
Wendy knew he was different from other
kids at an early age she took him to a
therapist who offered this advice don't
encourage it don't discourage it just
let him develop naturally I just do my
thing
Desmond remains extraordinarily
confident in who he is he does speaking
engagements he has started his own
foundation this will be his fourth pride
March where he hopes to spread a message
of acceptance his mom is doing the same
for parents out there who might have a
child like Desmond if you can just let
go that and just love your child
unconditionally as you should no matter
what that there really isn't a problem
if you want to really understand how
crazy this whole thing is if that's not
immediately obvious to you and how crazy
the acceptance of it is consider how
everybody would would would react how
everyone would universally react if
everything about this kids story was
exactly the same except that he was a
girl okay let's say that he's a girl
dressing up the exact same way
performing at nightclubs dollars thrown
at him or at her in this case hanging
out on on couches with adults joking
about doing drugs at the age of nine all
of it imagine that this rather than a
young boy in drag was a young girl into
you know burlesque which is roughly the
equivalent in that case everyone would
agree it's wildly inappropriate abusive
wrong sick exploitative etc etc etc but
because he's a boy it's okay
and why well because the LGBT Lobby says
it's okay and as I've explained a
million times on the left whatever the
LGBT Lobby says goes you know if they
say jump the left says how high
and that's the only reason that's the
only reason this is accepted in fact I
hear this argument it's not even an
argument it's just a deflection but it's
the closest thing to an argument I've
ever heard
in defense of the drag kid phenomenon
and the argument is along the lines of
well what about what about beauty
pageants for young for young girls I
don't hear you complaining about that
nobody complains about that what are you
talking about people complain about that
all the time including probably you if
you're on the Left that's it's you know
pretty much almost universally reviled
this this this is this thing of putting
young girls in beauty pageants now it
still happens people do it but unless
you're on that circuit and you're one of
those crazy mothers forcing your
daughter into these things almost
everybody else thinks that at a minimum
thinks it's weird that's exactly my
point that yeah a though not nearly as
bad thing does happen with girls and the
reason it's not nearly as bad is because
you know I've never been to a to a
beauty pageant so maybe I don't know
what I'm talking about but as far as I
know okay young girls of beauty pageants
aren't walking across a stage where
you've got adults hooting and hollering
and throwing dollar bills at them and
these beauty pageants are not being held
at nightclubs at 11:00 p.m. on a
Saturday or whatever right that's what's
happening with this kid there is a
there's a there's a blatant sexual
ization that's happening with this with
this young boy that isn't nearly as
blatant as it is with the beauty
pageants with with girls and yet and
that's and we're not even factoring in
all the drugs and everything else okay
and yet most people would agree that
this much tamer version of the same sort
of thing with girls is wrong and we
shouldn't be doing it there's no reason
why you need to take a six-year-old girl
or a nine-year-old girl and and dollar
up like that I didn't you know traipse
her across the stage is why do that let
her be a girl most people would agree
this this is the way I guess we could we
could sum it up most people would agree
for that nine year old girls should not
be dressing like grown women and that a
parent who addressed their nine-year-old
girl up like a grown woman is doing
something at a minimum inappropriate
almost everyone agrees and yet we
can't agree that you shouldn't dress
nine-year-old boys up like grown women
that's how completely crazy this all is
and there is there is no way to justify
it we are looking at something that is
so clearly unjust and wrong and we're
looking at and you know it's it this is
not just some academic point or argument
this is a a child more than one child I
mean he's just he's just one of a trend
who's being abused
and that abuse is being facilitated by
encouraged by and and and and profited
off of by his mother who you'd saw in
that in that clip before a clearly
disturbed woman and it's you know we
should we should not get to a point now
the left might want us to accept this as
normal that's the goal is to get to a
point where work where we're gonna say
oh you know just another drag kid but we
cannot ever allow that to happen we
should our immediate reaction every time
we see this should be repulsed
infuriated wanting justice to be done
for these kids and that needs to
continue to be our reaction and we'll
leave it there today thanks everybody
for watching thanks for listening
Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover
supervising producer Robert Stirling
technical producer Austin Stephens
editor Dany D'Amico audio mixer Robin
Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20 Barack Obama claims credit for
president Trump's booming economy Bernie
Sanders loses his mic to topless vegans
at a campaign rally and Mike Bloomberg
intends to win the presidency by telling
Americans how stupid they are then a
democratic Alabama Legislature
introduces a bill that would require men
to get vasectomies we will examine why
I'm skipping Birmingham on this
semester's campus speaking tour all that
more check it out on the Michael Noel's
show
[Music]